Віталя, дивись. Ось карта - раніше тут було це все,
поки радянські вчені не почали меліорацію і повністю не змінили ландшафт.
Ось це була вулиця.
Ми зараз знаходимося на Донбасі. Це зникле село.
Точніше, навіть чотири зниклих вулиці села.
Село називалося Софійськ, було засноване у 1780 році.
Трапляються монети від Катерини Другої і до ранніх Совітів.
На тому березі, швидше за все, була ставка Золотої Орди,
і тому тут трапляються знахідки по Золотій Орді.
Киянин Олексій Самков та Віталій Караневич з Лисичанська -
шукачі скарбів. Вони - одні із тисяч українців,
які у вільний час шукають монети та старожитності на полях та пасовищах.
За традицією, перед пошуком проводять своєрідне жертвопринесення
Дідові Хабару - покровителю шукачів скарбів.
Щоб задобрити Дідуся Хабара або Бабку-Копійку -
в принципі, це одне і те ж. Це такі ритуали існують у шукачів скарбів -
треба дати йому щось солоденьке. Ми зазвичай носимо із собою
цукор, або беремо якісь напої,
в даному випадку це у нас чай. Хтось цукерку закопує, хтось цукор.
Це такі повір'я - аби щось отримати, треба щось віддати.
Примовляючи: "Пару крапель з хлібцем земляному дідусеві".
Наливай. Все, давай! За знахідки! За кладуху!
Здається, магія діє. Майже одразу металодетектор
Олексія сигналізує: під ногами - щось металеве.
Зазвичай є пін-поінтер такий маленький - вказівник цілі.
За його допомогою шукають. Але я люблю руками все це робити -
м'яти землю. Реально заряджає.
Розбираєш, знаєш, що щось є - вже адреналін виділяється.
Перша знахідка - так званий "бухарський дирхем".
Найпоширеніший артефакт на полях України.
Бухарські дирхеми - це кришки з-під радянських лікеро-горілчаних виробів.
За ними можна відстежити, який лікеро-горілчаний завод
був найпопулярнішим у тій чи іншій місцевості -
Коростишівський, Житомирський, Артемівський, Краматорський,
Слов'янський, лікеро-горілчаний, вино-горілчаний завод.
Дуже сильно вживали алкоголь. Дуже сильно.
За Брежнєва - це просто "маст хев".
На кожних 10 квадратах пляшечка і кришечка-
безкозирочка
має бути присутня. Якщо немає - то Ви, напевно, не в Україні.
Віталік! Сміття в кишеню збирай, щоб показати,
наскільки привабливе це хобі фінансово.
Знахідки на кшталт кришок від горілки шукачі скарбів на своєму сленгу
називають "шмурдяк". Натомість цінні предмети - це "хабар".
Першим щастить Віталію. 25-річний студент-медик
має вже вісім років пошукового стажу.  Ось - зловили сигнал.
Іде як срібло, на приладі є шкали - різні метали.
Це не старовинний - мабуть,
або діти загубили, або пастух, який тут пасе худобу.
Матеріальна цінність мене не цікавить. Мене цікавить історична.
Звісно, приємно знаходити срібло, а не кришки,
але якби це був старовинний, емоцій було б набагато більше.
Найкрутіша для мене - це найстаріша моя знахідка, скіфський наконечник.
Це бронза, дуже класна знахідка, завжди приємно їх знаходити.
Ціна невелика. Їх дуже багато було. Це була зброя. Користувалися нею часто
і багато, тому ціна гривень 10-15.
За кілька метрів від місця знахідки хрестика
Віталію щастить вдруге.  Так, пул.
Ну, потри його, подивись. Там арабська в'язь.
Це монета Золотої Орди. Такі трапляються мідні і срібні.
Дуже рідко трапляються золоті.
Це ціна металу, грубо кажучи.
Якоїсь нумізматичноїцінності вони не мають, вони трапляються у скарбах -
там їх по 20 кілограмів, по 30.
Розбагатіти на пошуку можна - заперечувати я цього не буду, але це одиниці.
Це як лотерея. Ось за це і люблять цей вид пошуку.
Можливо, ось зараз сигнал, могла би бути золота монета,
яка змінила б усе життя Віталіка.
Віталік купив би собі Range Rover, Віталік купив би собі трикімнатну квартиру
в центрі Києва. І все - Віталік вже був би поважною людиною.
У нас 12 мільйонерів у клубі.
Утім, запевняють хлопці, витрачати вільний час
на пошук скарбів їх мотивує не перспектива збагачення.
Кажуть, головне - процес та емоції.
Усі ми з дитинства авантюристи,
всі ми надивилися фільмів про Індіану Джонса, всі ми знаємо про піратські скарби,
й це все розбурхує наші уми. Ми романтики по життю,
і в кожній людині живе маленький хлопчик з нездійсненною мрією,
який хоче знайти свій скарб. Розумієте? Це все
нереалізовані фантазії з дитинства. Вони виливаються ось у таке хобі.
Це однозначно краще, ніж полювання, рибалка -
не треба вбивати якихось риб, звірів. Ти просто зливаєшся
з матінкою природою і отримуєш енергію землі.
Ти повертаєшся додому і ти сповнений енергії.
Коли ти знаєш, що сигнал у тебе монетний,
у тебе виділяється повний спектр гормонів.
Плюс ще навантаження фізичні -
ти за день проходиш десь 7-12 кілометрів,
присідаєш разів 200-300,
викопуєш 200 ямок, 200 закопуєш.
Це таке хобі, яке дійсно викликає залежність.
Особливо якщо зима і замерз ґрунт,
а хочеться копати - люди на підвіконнях вазони копають свої.
Є такі, що газовими пальниками розігрівають ґрунт.
Палять багаття. Просто видовбують сокирами такі шматки землі,
додому привозять і потім відігрівають. Уже така ломка починається.
Хворі люди - що можна сказати.
"Врожайні" місця шукачі скарбів визначають за допомогою
історичних карт та документів, розпитують місцевих мешканців.
Деякі методи пошуку невідомі офіційній археології.
"Скарб серуна" - це коли кілька монет, маленька жменька монет,
знаходиться в одному місці. Коли людина ходила по малій або по великій нужді,
сідала, знімала штані ось так от - раз!
І весь дріб'язок, що був у неї в кишені, одразу бабах в одну ямку.
Можливо, тут хтось у 1946 році присів по нужді та загубив таку монетку.
Відстань малої та великої нужди - це поблизу доріг.
Поштових трактів якихось, польових доріг і зазвичай біля лісу.
Ти на відстані великої чи малої нужди просто йдеш лісом паралельно
до дороги й одразу трапляються такі знахідки - де по п'ять, де по десять монет.
Ще одна дуже неоднозначна техніка пошуку - як тільки ви йдете лугом,
біля річки та знаходите кришечки від вазеліну, вгадай, що там було?
Там корів доїли. І руки доярки змащували вазеліном. А де руки доярки
змащували вазеліном, там поруч шукай золоті кільця.
Це я тобі по секрету кажу…
Олексій за освітою психолог.
Пошуком з металодетектором почав займатися після нещасного випадку -
у 16 років, коли він ще жив у Краматорську, зазнав страшних опіків.
Олексій каже, що хобі допомогло йому соціалізуватися після травми.
Постраждало 65 відсотків тіла.
І з 2003 року я дуже сильно комплексував, сидів удома, ні з ким не спілкувався,
підключив інтернет і почав цікавитися, які хобі взагалі бувають у світі
і як далі жити в моєму становищі.
Знайшов українських однодумців на форумі, списався, почав спілкуватися,
придбав свій перший вживаний металошукач і пішов у найближчий город.
Знайшов ножиці, купу алюмінієвого дроту,
дуже зрадів - і з цього почалося моє хобі.
Нині Олексій - відома фігура у колах шукачів скарбів.
Декілька років тому він заснував громадську організацію
"Пошуково-історичний клуб "Камрад". "Камрадами" один одного називають
українські хобі-археологи - з німецької це слово перекладається як "товариш".
Біля сільського магазину Олексія одразу впізнають двоє місцевих.
30-річний Сергій, який працює водієм, хизується своїми знахідками.
О! Це ти все з детектором знайшов?
Все ось тут, так?
Так, по місцевості.
Копаєш давно?
Роки чотири вже.
Азарт. Великий азарт.
Коли перший катерининський п'ятак знайшов - це взагалі було щось.
Вау, офігіти - це в тебе цілий мішок монет?
Дєньга - це дуже крута монета, дуже рідкісна.
І сохран, диви, чудовий. Це ось ця літописна:
"Муха по полю пішла, муха дєнєжку знайшла".
Ось це вона - ця дєньга. Муха Цокотуха.
Як рибалка рибалку бачить здалеку, так і камрад камрада:
"Привіт, що знайшов, покажи, які знахідки…"
Можна розмовляти дуже довго, нескінченно на спільні теми.
А чим ще тут займатися? Або пити горілку, або займатися пошуком
з детектором і отримувати задоволення від життя.
Можемо поїхати покопати?
Нині в Україні кількасот тисяч шукачів скарбів.
Копають всі - від безробітних до чиновників та бізнесменів,
від Карпат до Донбасу. Останніми роками явище набуло ознак субкультури -
з десятками груп у соцмережах, власним сленгом,
ритуалами та фестивалями. Така пошукова лихоманка
викликає занепокоєння професійних археологів,
яких в Україні лише декілька сотень. Вони нарікають,
що цінні артефакти здебільшого опиняються у приватних колекціях,
а "чорні археологи" руйнують історичні пам'ятки.
Що таке об'єкт археологічної спадщини?
Це не просто якийсь курган видимий, якесь городище -
здебільшого це ділянки культурного прошарку,
які зазвичай не видно нефахівцю, але які містять
інформацію про ту чи іншу культурну епоху.
Якщо ми з цього комплексу за допомогою металодетектора
виймаємо весь метал, руйнується цілісність сприйняття
цього археологічного об'єкта, і тоді дослідження,
які будуть там проведені - сьогодні, завтра, або через 100 чи 200 років -
не дадуть тих наукових результатів. Сьогодні деякі науковці
кажуть, що більшість металевих знахідок
з глибини щонайменше 50 сантиметрів в Україні вже вийнято.
Тобто це завдало непоправної шкоди об'єктам археологічної спадщини
на всій території нашої держави.
Тим часом на розораному полі - найцікавіша знахідка
за день пошуку. Срібник Золотої Орди.  Як тобі? А!?
Знаходили тут уже? Я думав, я перший. Це найчистіше срібло.
Це данг. Це десь 12-13 століття. Приємно підіймати срібло,
яке пролежало понад 600 років.
Нумізматичної цінності монета не має - в інтернеті такі продаються за кілька доларів.
А скільки їх ще розкидано по полях країни, відомо лише Діду Хабару -
покровителю шукачів скарбів. Олексій запевняє: до чорних археологів,
які грабують скіфські кургани та копають з метою наживи, він та його товариші
стосунку не мають, а члени пошукового клубу
зобов'язуються не зачіпати археологічних пам'яток. За це в Україні
є кримінальна відповідальність. Олексій каже, що шукають лише там,
куди офіційна археологія навряд дістанеться.
Як бачите, поле переоране, ми проводимо пошук по розораному полю,
таким чином рятуючи знахідки.
Тому що плуги розбивають знахідки,
пошкоджують монети. Пошкоджують цікаву металопластику,
зокрема церковну. Ми рятуємо це від сільськогосподарських знарядь,
від добрив. Металошукач реагує лише на 35 сантиметрів на монету.
Приблизно на штик лопати.
Так само оре і плуг. Глибше не бере.
Олексій каже, що цінні з історичної точки зору знахідки вони віддають у музеї.
Нещодавно передали у Бахмут старовинний козацький казан.
Натомість науковці критикують навіть пошук на переораних полях.
Адже проконтролювати хто, де і як глибоко копає - неможливо.
До того ж, більша частина археологічних об'єктів в Україні ще просто не виявлена.
Офіційні археологи воліють обмежити використання
металодетекторів в Україні - така заборона
діє в деяких країнах.
Тим часом шукачі скарбів посилаються на досвід Великобританії,
де любительська археологія дозволена та співпрацює з професійною,
а за знахідки передбачена винагорода
в розмірі повної вартості артефакту.